didier revoir notre correspondant à
moscou nous sommes ali en ligne à
présent avec florent parmentier bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
enseignant à sciences po paris auteur
des chemins de l'état de droit la voie
étroite re des pays entre europe et et
russie j'ai envie de vous interroger
d'abord sur les sanctions qui vont être
décidées sûrement dans les heures qui
viennent beaucoup de réunions ont lieu
aujourd'hui j'essaie autant conseil
européen quelles peuvent être ses
sanctions suite à cette intervention
russe en ukraine
il est évident que le jeu de champions
auquel nous allons assister doit être
beaucoup plus puissant que le premier
jeu de champion qui déjà ce premier jeu
de champion était supérieur à ce qui
avait été envisagé effectué en 2014 au
moment de au moins dans la première
guerre contre le contre l'ukraine
l'allemagne a déjà franchi un pas qui
était nord stream 2 du côté des
etats-unis du royaume-uni on a on a
continué avec des sanctions financières
la question qui va se poser dans les
prochaines heures c 'est de l'exclusion
de la russie du swift c'est à dire des
systèmes de paiements internationaux
qui peut avoir un effet considérable sur
l'économie russe ce que les européens
vont essayer de faire des américains
également ce n'est pas d'aller se lancer
dans une opération militaire don pour
laquelle nous ne sommes ni prêt ni
g1 mis en position de le faire en
revanche il est bien entendu que les
menaces qui ont été proférées par le
président russe ne sont pas acceptables
et que par conséquent de ne pas
renforcer les sanctions maintenant
posera un problème de crédibilité pour
les européennes pour les états unis donc
je pense que dans les prochaines heures
le probable lepreau le résultat tout ça
ça va être effectivement de est bien de
d'exclure la russie du tube du programme
swift avec
des conséquences effectivement qu'on ne
mesure pas et très certainement avec
d'autres jeux de sanctions la russie a
anticipé par le passé parce qu'elle a
déjà été soumise elle est encore un des
sanctions économiques européennes suite
à l'annexion de la crimée en 2014
la russie a anticipé sa dette est très
faible elle a constitué un stock de
devises est-ce que l'on peut vraiment
être efficace avec ses sanctions envers
la russie aujourd'hui
je crois qu'il y à deux niveaux à cela
analyse le premier niveau est celui des
dirigeants russes est-ce que l'admirent
poutine est prêt à payer un prix élevé
en matière de sanctions la réponse est
très vraisemblablement oui je pense
qu'il a montré tout simplement dans dans
son mode de décision dans l'accélération
qui a lieu depuis lundi dernier dans le
fait qu'il a montré un conseil de
sécurité dans lequel l'ensemble des
personnes du régime ont été associés et
qui les a forcés en quelque sorte à
arques à faire de la reconnaissance de
des républiques autoproclamées de donner
tes de lougansk un des éléments de la
politique à ce moment là on peut penser
qu'en haut lieu il n'y aura pas de
défaillance ou de ou deux j'allais dire
de deux sorties par rapport à par
rapport à la ligne qui a été tracé par
vladimir poutine en revanche je pense
qu'il ya un deuxième niveau de réponse
qu'elle celui de la population on l'a vu
la population russe est relativement
divisés sur cet européen sme il n'y a
pas d'unanimité on parlait des 43% de
russes qui à ce stade exclu et en tout
cas ne voulait pas entendre une action
militaire sur contre l'ukraine il est
vraisemblable que à mesure que les jours
passeront sept ce nombre de personnes
qui sera hostile à un conflit augmentera
tout simplement parce que les premiers
cadavres qui reviendront aux roses 7,7
c'est à dire cette conséquence la et au
niveau de la population l'impact que
devrait avoir les sanctions c'est de
mener ce qu'on appelle la guerre du
frigo contre la guerre de la télévision
la télévision montrera des images
parties prenantes etc mais si demain
vous n'avez plus accès incertain de
biens de consommation si vous voyez que
ces biens ont augmenté en de manière
drastique il est fort à parier qu'une
partie de la population non seulement
voilà se dira que peut-être que
l'ukraine ce ne serait pas sans conflits
et et qu'en tout cas ce sont bien ces
achats qui sont menacés donc comme
souvent pour que les sanctions marchent
il faut qu'elle soit forte qu'elle
frappe au portefeuille qu'elles soient
ciblées et donc c'est peut-être cela ou
qu'elles nous allons assister dans les
prochaines zones parce que jusqu'à
présent c'était l'élite russe qui était
ciblé selon vous c'est si les russes
finalement voit au quotidien les effets
de ces sanctions qu'il y aura peut-être
un désaveu du chef du kremlin qui reste
quand même très populaire en russie
aujourd'hui et qui s'appuie sur une
propagande dans la télévision d'état et
dans toute la presse qui qui n'est pas
libre en russie qui peut s'appuyer sur
cette propagande justement pour être
précis
le but n'est pas de cibler la population
elle même le but est de effectivement dû
cibler ce qu'on appelle des oligarques
c'est à dire les fortunes qui sont
autour de vladimir poutine qui tire le
pays et de faire en sorte en quelque
sorte enfin de ne montrer à la
population que ce n'est pas elle qui est
visée ce sont les personnes qui
représentent le pays qui pour les
oligarques n'ont pas été élus et qui
finalement ont lancé dans une politique
qui est extrêmement aventuriste en tout
cas beaucoup plus que ce soit quand on
assister jusqu'à présent beaucoup plus
certainement que 2014 là il va être
meilleur en ukraine beaucoup plus qu'en
2008 la guerre en géorgie là on peut
estimer effectivement qu'on a franchi
un nouveau
palier et que nous ne sommes pas très
bien en fait ne savons pas très bien
nous sommes aujourd'hui et nous ne
savons pas très bien finalement
jusqu'où l'ukraine pourra résister et on
l'a finalement quel sera le gdir le
résultat final de la crise auxquelles
nous assistons alors
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
florent parmentier je rappelle que vous
êtes enseignant à sciences po et auteur
des chemins de l'état de droit la voie
étroite des pays
entre l'europe et la russie merci merci
à vous